To convert age to age with months, we know we're
going to need to add some fraction to the age variable. Since
there are 12 months in a year, we know 12 will
be the denominator. Now, let's think carefully about age. For a
given year, someone who was born in March would be
older than someone born in September. So we need to subtract
the birth month from 12 to reflect this. This should make
sense, since someone born in March would be born on the
third month of the year. So our numerator here would
be seven. So for the 36 year old born in
March, their age would be 36.75. If the user was
born in September and was also 36, then the user's
age would be 36.25. So let's run this bit of
code and convert our age variable, measured in years, to
age with months. And it looks like I made a
mistake. I forgot to include my data frame for DOB month.
Now we're ready to go.